lying is a natural human trait that lets
you manipulate the way you want others
to see you there are certain signs you
can look for if you think someone might
be lying to you
I movement when right-handed people are
lying they look up at the right
left-handed people look up to the left
other signs of lying are if they don't
blink close their eyes very slowly or
contrastingly blink a lot or break eye
contact
hiding body parts they hide their mouth
eyes or throat with their hands
grooming they may also adjust their hair
or clothes and movement anxiety can
cause itching or chilliness in the face
causing a liar to bite or lick their
lips or play with their ears head move
they move their head around quickly
before they answer a question audible
cues they clear their throat or swallow
before answering a question and their
vocal pitch Rises yeah no can you tell
who's lying
my cousin he I was I was going to a
party and I did not want him to come
with me so I told them I was just going
to a friend's house
probably this morning when somebody cut
me off and I yelled at him told my
coworker today that his breath smelled
bad so are you good at spotting liars